So there's something interesting going on.
And I'm sort of I'm sure actually as to the
direction things are going and I want to see
what you think.
And I'm talking about the Democratic primary.
The Democratic primary sort of has evaporated
during the virus without actually being finished.
Although we were pretty close to wrapping
it up.
So here's how I kind of see what's taken place
so far.
We had the beginning of the Democratic primary.
We had debates, hard fought many candidates.
Candidates started dropping off.
We had our first votes in Iowa, in New Hampshire.
This feels like years ago because so much
has happened since.
And then we had South Carolina, South Carolina.
Joe Biden wins a bit by a bigger than expected
margin.
The momentum clearly shifts.
Mayor Peet drops out and endorses Biden.
Amy Klobuchar drops out and endorses Biden.
Kamala Harris endorses Biden.
Biden gets more wins on Super Tuesday.
And it starts to seem as though the window
is closing for Bernie Sanders.
Bloomberg endorses Biden keeps winning.
He wins Super Tuesday.
He wins Super Tuesday, too.
Three.
We now have Joe Biden ahead, 12 15 to 9-0-9,
a lead of 306 delegates.
Tulsi drops out and endorses Biden, much to
the dismay of both her supporters and Bernie's
supporters.
We were supposed to have a primary today in
Georgia, but it's been postponed due to the
virus.
Puerto Rico was supposed to vote in five days.
That's postponed due to the virus.
And now the primary is barely being discussed.
Now I understand why, of course, people are
staying home.
In some states, at least people are trying
to deal with the Corona virus pandemic.
But what is the path forward?
Because on the one hand, the entire pandemic
has actually re-energized Bernie supporters
who are saying Corona virus makes the case
for Medicare for all so much more clear.
Biden's M.I.A.
Bernie's doing livestreams, a sort of resurgence
in some corners of the Internet anyway.
For Bernie Sanders and indeed, Joe Biden has
been missing.
He resurfaced yesterday, did a short scream
about the pandemic.
It didn't go well, I guess it was.
He had a podium at home and it sort of looked
like his living room, although it might have
been a greenscreen with a picture of his living
room.
I couldn't really tell.
Everything going wrong, including the teleprompter,
failing for Joe Biden.
Take a look at this short clip.
Beef up the number of responders dealing with
the crush, this crush of cases.
And in addition to that, in addition to that,
we have to make sure that we are we are in
a position that we are.
Well, let me let me go two seconds.
I'm so confident the president must use the
Fence Production Act so it wasn't good.
And then looking at polling, we're also getting
less and less polling data because polling
has also slowed down due to the pandemic.
Looking at just recent polls over the last
six days, we have national polls from last
Wednesday where Biden was plus 24 and plus
21 pull out of Georgia where Biden was plus
44 Thursday in Connecticut, saying Biden is
plus 17.
And then from Friday, we had a hypothetical
matchup poll where both Biden and Bernie are
ahead of Trump by six and then a national
poll which has Biden plus twelve according
to that poll, the lead shrinking for Biden
heading into the weekend.
But again, no polling data at all from this
week yet.
Biden's lead on Bernie seemingly shrinking
a little bit.
So what happens now?
I mean, is it over in the sense that the remaining
primaries, if they happen, will simply be
a formality?
Does Corona virus change the perspectives
on Bernie and Biden so drastically?
Is it one of those black swan events that
creates a new window of opportunity for Bernie
Sanders where there before a did not exist
one?
Is this why Bernie Sanders hasn't dropped
out?
And then bigger picture.
Is anyone even thinking about the primary?
And most importantly, I'm seeing some people
start to say there's not going to be an election
in November.
So we don't even really have to pay attention.
That's very dangerous thinking.
It is incredibly unlikely that the election
in November is actually postponed.
We already talked about the legal issues around
that and around the fact that there is a deadline
in December for electors to place their votes
on the basis of how their respective states
voted.
Ideally, things will have improved dramatically
by November, although under Donald Trump,
maybe not.
We're now hearing he's thinking of letting
it rip, so to speak.
But the odds of postponing a presidential
election are very, very low.
And anybody counting on that is unlikely to
be right.
So let me know how you see things.
What do you think is going on with the Democratic
primary?
Has anything actually shifted due to Corona
virus or is it just like we saw before?
More loud on Cleves, on Twitter and read it
and the Internet and where it particularly
if you haven't voted yet.
If your state hasn't yet voted.
I would love to hear what your perspective
is on what's going
on as well